this week Armstrong's sons are
auctioning off many of his personal
items including his flight suit flags
and medallions that were launched into
space
Omar Villafranca is inside the heritage
auction house in Dallas he spoke to
Armstrong's son first son's I should say
first on CBS this morning Omar good
morning good morning the president of
Heritage Auctions called us the holy
grail of auctions and some of these
items are very unique we're talking
space themed jewelry also letter signed
by the president if you move over here
we have medals and medallions
commemorating Apollo 11 but of course
the big thing people want to hear about
are the big-ticket items some of the
things for sale will be a test pilot
helmet of course and and some space
gloves but this flag this flag is
special taken and flown on the moon from
Armstrong's personal collection they're
expecting a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for that and this it's a lunar
module plaque taken to the moon given to
the astronauts current bid on that
sixty-five thousand dollars and the
Armstrong brothers say they hope that
this auction inspires the next
generation of space travelers American
space exploration was never the same
after the summer of 1969 an estimated
530 million people around the world
watched live from their living rooms and
street corners as astronaut Neil
Armstrong took the first steps on the
lunar surface this is I think I believe
Germany era NASA flight suit and one
that dad wore now many pieces of
American history that were blasted into
orbit with Armstrong are going under the
hammer to the highest bidder I think a
lot of people have a personal connection
with the Apollo program and the moon
landing in general it may be it takes
them back to a time in their childhood
or even in their adulthood they remember
where they will remember where they were
they were or there's something that they
connect with that or or maybe it's had
an impact on their life in some way
so you just hope that people
get positive energy from from from these
things why now what why put all this
stuff up now
if we were to pass these things down to
our kids they they would not know the
stories they would not they would not
recognize that connections that that we
recognize so that that meant that we
needed to do something sooner rather
than later
is it tough to let go of pieces of your
dad's work your dad's legacy it's a bit
of a struggle but you know we've gotta
kind of look at the bigger picture and
hopefully it's gonna go to some people
that you know will get the inspiration
from it what these pieces are are the
literal nuts and bolts that are left
over avid space collector robert Perlman
says Armstrong's most prized items like
his spacesuit and spacecraft are safely
housed in the Smithsonian but he
believes the thousands of other
keepsakes up for sale will help us
understand one of history's greatest
explorers he was the most famous person
on earth in 1969 and we know him best
when his face was covered so this allows
us to sort of lift that visor and expose
who he was through the items that he
kept that story gives you chills for all
the right reasons what a hero he was
legacy for this country
thanks to Omar